Hello my name is bob hopkins. I'm a long time resident of naman. I've.
Came here primarily as a political gesture and as a consequence i continue that these lines of interest within him
and i've been involved in the years with. Name in news. Very active within the newman community school.
In him and a whole committee. Currently. Secretary and public officer of the name and environment center.
Plus a few others. Various organizations associated with it. And presently i'm working at the newman recycling center.
Now look there have been times when i possibly could have fitted that bill but.
One doesn't mind tiny's particular title for terry law.
Well i first came to him in here the year before the festival happened so i knew him
and tended to stand in my mind i was working for a chap in sydney who wanted to set up a primal therapy center in the
country. He was looking for. Undeveloped land. In the real estate agents in leeds moral said undeveloped land the land.
You one named and. So i came to nimbin here in nineteen seventy two. He was very much just a really.
Forgotten little town it was a tan in the middle of a rural decline. Most of the shops are rather empty or.
Being lived in his residence. The. Community was very poor. Run them and people living on not a great deal of income.
They were found societal over the place.
I travelled on from there and returned to lose more the next year's student of the teachers college. And.
As fate would have it i was right on the spot. When the festival happened.
Well yeah it's interesting in a sort of historical perspective. We. My wife and myself were both pretty young.
At right. My son was born on the second day of the festival and.
My wife and i were both pretty young at that time pretty unsure about doing it by ourselves. We.
From the point of view of the fact that birth and beyond is a home birth organizations existed now.
In name been for the last seventeen years. It's interesting to makes it an interesting. Time capsule.
We tried to get a doctor or a midwife at that time to attend. The.
But found it very difficult so we went to the northern star and advertised for a doctor a midwife
and at that stage they wouldn't accept the ad because it was considered to be
and i was saying it's interesting in light of all the changes that are going on around the area that these.
It gives an interesting. Sense of the passing of time and the changes that have been wrought by this is saudi.
The first of all the fact that the tanning.
A pretty fundamental way because what it meant was that the people at lot of the people who came here decided to stay.
It's a beautiful area land was cheap land was plentiful. And the feeling was so good at the festival that.
A lot of people wish to maintain that sense of satisfaction. The festival itself was also. Can see.
As an ongoing festival it wasn't it. It was part of a series of biennials festivals that.
Were run by the national union of union of history and university students. And were story into.
What had happened in the past was that festivals.
Tended to set up for a couple of weeks people would hang their paintings. A few drama or activities would go on.
But this one.
And then at the end everyone would pack up and go away
but with this one it was conceived as an ongoing festival of lifestyle.
And that's exactly what happened in the why i see it is that the festival. Has never really stopped.
It's been an ongoing. Twenty year. Exercise in people seeking to bring about a fundamental change in the law stalls.
Community politics. The why that people relate to each other and to the environment particularly. And it still goes on.
It's still happening all the time it's got a remarkable sort of history of. Achievements behind it now.
In things as diverse as. Well birth and beyond popularizing home birth. And empowering women along the why.
The changes in the multiple occupancy laws that were one of the first changes in ten years for very long time.
Environmental political thrust that came from here that started and. Culminated in the terai forest.
Protests the man in the forest protests that just went on to other areas as people realize the environmental.
Imperatives. The alternative energy. Lobby has been particularly persistent here.
Which is resulted in the formation of the rainbow power company. The music that is coming out of here has been a times.
Most particularly name been. Which is again reflected the attitudes. In the last star through the music.
Do you know what else happened. The last twenty. What is particularly bad naman. Is a larry can.
A particularly larry king a straggly
and tendency to seek to go through what people consider to be appropriate within themselves.
You know why that's full of a combination of humor. Political confrontation. That are reflected a creative.
That was most manifest in the culture through the music. In the nineteen seventies music.
Was a real powerful cultural force it's become absorbed more and more by the industry over the years.
But the music in women is remind. There's always been within within him been a tendency to express the un ings for.
Community. For the in the magic of the life and earth by spirituality through the music. Yeah it's not really my forte.
But. A lot of people have moved on.
For a lot of different reasons out of frustration
and maybe that they haven't achieved what they thought they were going to or maybe the fan that their.
Their actual life. Doesn't necessarily correspond with the original dream.
But a lot of people have studied the communities of continue to grow and strengthen and expand and developing and.
Unwise that serve a particular nade of the people who are here. For me. Nimbin was a political possibility.
Or it offered the opportunity for a political possibility that we touched upon.
I guess in the sixty's during the times of the viet nam conflict. And all that was associated with that.
And it seemed as though naman was a place where it was possible to actually create some sort of new society which was
based upon this new alternative way of thinking. And it does.
It offers these possibilities it continues to offer these possibilities. Because naman is a media. Nine. Nationally.
People will notice things that come out of the name and. The initiatives.
In all realms of sort of political and community life.
The ability to make people who are interested in working in the same areas as you are out of the particular and they.
For instance through the community school. In other areas it was difficult to establish. Systems of alternative.
Schooling because of the. Small numbers of people in name than. With the prevailing social situation which.
Didn't allow a great deal for the children of the new settlers.
The tendency to want to create an expression of an alternative education system.
Was able to succeed simply because of the. Large numbers of people who were in the area. And who desired this.
Like a lot of other things. Societies chinese diver the. Since then and a lot of the initiatives that was.
Out of that the community school have now been absorbed into the central school system.
And while the community school still manages to exist it doesn't have the same.
Support that it once did have this could be a combination of providing a lot changes in people's attitude towards
schooling.
But i think to a large extent it is it's kemah bad as a consequence to the chinese that have been forged by comparison
with the providing system. Or by this. The providing system.
Looking at what we were doing at the community school and altering their approach in order to accommodate more.
The alternative came up the alternative education thrust.
Twenty's is a long time a lot of changes happen in twenty years twenty years ago women weren't allowed in public
but society has undergone a huge transformation during that period of time.
Organic agriculture is now being recognised as being an almost imperative for australian farmers.
The senses of environmental. Imperatives of also chinese. Niman is almost bought about. I mean mina's.
Newman has manifested. What it said have to do. In the sense of.
Putting a series of particular issues into the public consciousness. This is where the challenge laws the name and.
To be able to look at the next twenty years. And lie down a vision that will hold for that will. In twenty years time.
Be considered as being pertinent. And fundamental to nature of society. But there is also a longer.
I'm that is there the original. Aquarius festival.
Concentrated on a sense of tribes and community in relation to the environment.
And this is one of the things that continues to attract me here and.
And what i see is happening is that there is a particular culture being formed.
For the earth to be sustainable that needs a sense of. Tribalism.
Of people who have grown up in a particular area who are committed to living in a particular area.
Who get to know the area. Intimately. Who forge an ongoing. Culture. That takes into account.
The area in which you leave. And. I guess the in the long run. The value of name and will be saying.
After a two or three generations and.
It's only then really that naman will be able to be saying whether
or not we've created a society that is equal to the top.
The twenty year periods are useful in so far as that they do provide a measuring point of health. We've come.
But there is still. The challenge there for us to continue to put into effect.
Whatever the vision ease at any one particular point of time so much time is spent.
Just holding ground against the forces that are out there that would potentially overrun.
This point of view that exists here in him and. And so as a consequence. There are a lot of areas of social life that.
A possibly lacking in terms of the vision.
We've currently got the situation in town where people are getting upset about the state of. Street behavior.
And drug related issues. And this is an area where. Which i see is very pertinent to the whole idea of name and.
It seems fundamental to me that. Nima needs to rise to this to confront. The problem of drugs. In this society.
And look at it in a new why. Implement new directions. Rather than resorting to.
The old wise but it's very difficult to step outside. The dominant. Thinking forms in. And actually implement change.
And change that are in relation to the to the drug. Issues in name and. What we need is a. I radical.
Reappraisal of the drug situation how it affects us to look at what it's doing to our society.
And trying to create some new form of. Approach to the whole the issue of drug use. To do this.
We really need to step outside. The whole of the dominant society. And forget the particular lor's.
And create almost in a theatrical form a new scenario a new paradigm for. Possibility.
Marijuana has been associated with naman. Pretty much right from the start.
As it was a substance that was taken out by the early hippies. And it was one of the as. It does become a sacrament.
In those early days. It still does have this aspect about it.
But what's happened over the course of time is that the price for this particular substance. Has risen alarmingly.
And because it has such a cash value. It was one of the first things that people stop sharing.
Where they are able to reenter into the. Consumption by society without having to commit a large slice of your life.
To working in offices or working. For corporations or working in business and call the us.
And although it is seen to be part of the freedom of nimon it is part of the reason.
Why naman is selling the seeds of its destruction and this to me just. Pinpoint even more directly.
The imperative for china in this direction.
Within the drug issue particularly at the moment in niman vast sums of money.
In at the moment in nimbin large amounts of money. Transferred between people in the sile. Of marijuana.
None of this money. Returns itself to the general community it goes always to individual people.
If in name and we could regulate. The silo of marijuana in much the same way that it happens.
The best model for where it is happening is in holland with marijuana has a sort of quasi legal stuff as.
Marijuana in holland has a quasi legal status. Where it's sold in. Coffee shops. It's taxed.
And the responsibility is on the actual seller. To make sure that they have that i take responsibility.
Because the fact that they're involved in selling an intoxicating substance.
If we were able to do the same thing in women. We would have. The people who sorry.
Let's just give a scenario of a possible change. If we had. The run by a cafe for instance. Selling pot.
Over the cantar then. What we could do would be to undercut the street price. Which would eliminate the hustle.
That happens on the street. But eliminates the competitiveness of the volunteers.
He would take away the possibility for the. Sort of parasitical chemical. Heroin's the cocaine sellers that.
Are attracted by the. The large amounts of money. By the illegality.
By the fact that there is an element of opposition to the lords. And these people have been bleeding.
The community drawing. If we had the right back half way. Selling it then i could. It would be.
I conceive of if the rainbow cafe was selling. Part of the cantar.
Then i would take on a responsibility for administering the whole saying it would be up to them. To make sure that the.
On the sort of congestion or that there isn't the sort of congestion. That exists in front of the rind.
Cafe the hustling. The dealing that upsets and out rises to a speech that is. Local the lawyer.
At the moment alcohol is solved without any responsibility being placed on the dispenses of alcohol.
To really look up to the people that. The alcohol the fakes that they sell to. I would say that. Pubs.
Should be able to or should be night to provide childcare centers. Social workers. People who just.
Mingle with the crowds make sure that nobody who is looking like they are becoming drunk
and becoming a problem to themselves and to the society. Should not be allowed to procure any more alcohol.
In the same way. Apply the same line of reasoning to marijuana silos. The people whose dispense. The drugs should be.
My to be. To be held responsible for the consequences of what goes down. Following the marijuana. Silos. At the moment.
Because the whole thing. Has an illegal status. It's outside the realm of society to really regulate. We.
You can have the police come in and pick off a few dealers.
But by the time that they have worked their way through the mountain of pipe or the fingerprinting.
Identification the photo was. Another. Two people could easily have joined the street sellers by that time.
And at the end of the day the people who've been arrested are just back on the streets and dealing again.
It's just that the. The war on drugs approach. Has and would. Can any country in the world.
In fact it's being can a productive in the sime why that is being can a productive here.
There is a disproportionate sense of values. Being put down to the young people.
A week's work can be yielded three hundred dollars banan support can potentially yield you four hundred
or five hundred dollars. It's promoted.
Suspicion between people because all of the fact that your own party is likely to be ripped off. Saul on the streets.
You there's no way you can try said there's no protection that you have. So people tend to be counted suspicious of.
As everyone. Paranoid. Potentially even sort of heading in the direction of.
Taken violent measures to protect their crops these are the drug problems when they. Ripple through a big drug problem.
Not necessarily the. The street saying. Which in a lot of cases. Doesn't necessarily relight. To drugs.
But as i've heard with drugs because of the types of people who come looking for an easy way to make money.
And they see society where things are a bit more open and tolerated.
Than any other parts of a struggle that i've been candid. Nimbin regularly used to haul these. Anti heroin.
Matings as heroin has sort of risen from time to. Time into a state of prominence and.
Pretty widespread use throughout the town. And public meetings have been held at two or three year intervals.
At which time. It was more of an opportunity for people to vent their anger. Their frustration.
Generally to attack the police for not doing enough. Attack. Indiscriminately. Or uses. No matter what they were using.
It did nothing really to bring a bad a sense of progress or harmony.
So myself i started to notice that people started to believe what others said about their particular habits.
Marijuana users tended to actually become to feel that they were somehow
or other the outcast of society that they were a criminal it diminished their own sense of self esteem.
Their own sense of being their own sense of value in law. And so i figured that. The time had come when.
I just had to try and bring about a chinese because the more that people felt victimized by the.
The anti drug feelings.
The the less that are likely to apply an active role in determining the future of their own society that is more.
They were more likely to keep out of society. Try and. God. Sources of income through ground part.
Which really didn't do a great deal to wards. Making this a better society or better community to leaving.
And so i i stepped out from the cover of anonymity. To take on the drug lords.
Which in itself is pretty fascinating because the. The whole nature of drug use in societies.
Has implications and repercussions right throughout. So many structure of law and. I stood for parliament. Last years.
Being on a. I stood. Parliament last year on a drug reform ticket. Ok. Yeah. I nine tined.
Up to the last big heroin meeting which was held in nineteen ninety. I formed a group e.
A cool million normal nimbin which was a bit of a pun based.